my name is Garth Henson as was mentioned
I do
Disney Company I've been with the
company about five years now thank you
that that's how I feel still every day I
worked out of the Seattle office for
about four years I work with corporate
technology there
what we do is basically platform to
laying anything we need to build to
enable the different brands to do what
they need to do so right now I'm working
with the SPN we work with ABC News we
work with Parks and Resorts we work with
all the different brands from an
infrastructure architecture application
basically whatever we need to build
right now it's kind of fun because most
of what I build is node on the backend
and we do full stack all the way up then
we do react on the front end and so most
of the stuff we're working is JavaScript
end to end one of the reasons I am
excited about this talk is this is
something that is an ongoing project is
we're trying to figure out which
applications we should move to not only
into the cloud but into a service
architecture the nice thing is that in
most cases we can keep running
JavaScript end to end with maybe a
little bit of bash in there for some of
our docker containers and entry points
and that type of thing so that's what
we're gonna talk about today
serverless is one of those very
interesting terms it's been a buzzword
for a long time and it's one that I
really don't like honestly serverless
sounds like we just don't have service
anymore which of course we know they
just are going to go away and everything
runs on magic right that's at least at
Disney that's how it works but but what
is serverless server this computing
based on a Wikipedia definition here
it's really a cloud computing execution
model it's a process it's a way of
thinking in which the cloud provider
dynamically manages allocation of
machine resources and then the pricing
itself is generally based on the actual
consumption of the processing so
whatever you use is what you pay for so
obviously that means I'm not there yes
arms up and so this this diagram kind of
breaks down into a couple different
categories all of the things we would
talk about as a cloud offering and so
most of these I hope many people in here
familiar with some of the different
burrows
odd categories is is pretty common
you're gonna have
infrastructure-as-a-service whether
that's an on-prem data center that
you're having to pull resources from an
out gate or you're using ec2 instances
or you're using compute instances from
whatever provider cloud provider you use
you basically have to provision what you
need and you have to assemble all of
your pieces before you can deploy the
code to it right that's that we're
familiar with that and then you've got
the SAS offerings which I think most of
us are also familiar with where I just
don't either want to take the time or
the money to build it I'd rather put the
money into paying for the service and
just use it where it stands and let them
manage the SaaS let them manage
everything else and the support layers
we just don't want to take that on
ourselves so we're gonna buy the service
from somebody else use it in place and
continue processing and then more
recently we're getting more and more
capabilities of moving things into the
cloud on top of your past offering so
you've got your platform as a service
that you're going to start leveraging
and what's really interesting and we'll
talk a little bit more about this is
with things like Direct Connect for AWS
and there's other things with with some
of the other service offerings as well
you can actually start running some of
these platform offerings on your own
private networks and so even though it's
still managed completely remotely by
your service provider you can actually
run it on your private network as well
so you starting to get the best of both
worlds where you can start leveraging
these other pieces but yet keep your
connectivity the way it needs to be for
your broader application and then on
this diagram as well you'll notice that
towards the top here we have the
functions and the database is a service
some of your things like your no sequels
firebase or you've got your dynamo DB
type of thing those are typically what
we group into what we would really call
server lists those are the things that
basically everybody says oh yeah just
use it it'll it'll scale and you just
pay for what you use which is true but
we need to make sure we understand what
that actually means so this is if we're
in a smaller room I would pause for
questions but I
say now if you have questions please do
come talk to me afterwards I don't have
all the answers I'm still learning a lot
of this but I do want to share what
we've what we've figured out so far so
of course once we understand all of
these this means this brings us to the
conclusion I've heard so many times
no more server is yeah everything's
awesome we'd have to worry about
anything anymore no actually all it
means is it's not my servers the the
problem or the the hiccups that the
things we have to be aware of don't go
away they just move to another location
the concerns we have to be aware of just
change it they don't go away why do we
care why does it matter well if we look
at the benefits of service there's
several and then there's other things we
have to be aware of as we move into this
architecture
first of all cost cost really is almost
unanimously cited as the driving reason
to move to serverless adoption
everybody's like oh it's just cheaper
everything should be service
everything's cheaper which can be on
demand execution built-in elasticity
optimizes utilization uptime reliability
everything's higher this is this is all
true this is great it's fantastic but I
want to see there's a there's a specific
word right there the savings can be
insane if they're built correctly for
the appropriate applications they are
incredibly cheaper to run
however there's that key word of if we
build them properly and we use it used
it for the appropriate application it's
cheaper so keep that in mind
scalability by definition we're using
serverless offerings we're using hosted
and managed solutions and so scalability
is built into it reliability it's really
based off your providers SLA so we have
all of these great potential benefits
that we can get out of moving
applications into a service architecture
but we need to be aware I love this
quote the most common currency to pay
for benefits
in our application architecture its
complexity so how do we get I don't know
if you I don't have the diagram up here
but you've got different pivots that you
can actually pull on in any application
right any architecture management comes
down says hey this has to run less
expensively okay great it's gonna be
slower now or it's going to be there's
only certain things we can pull on and
in order to reduce the cost and increase
the performance and the scalability and
reliability the easiest way to do that
is to increase complexity now what does
that look like though well in this
diagram we kind of see the stepping
stones between moving from our old
monolithic applications into a standard
what we would call the microservice
infrastructure or ecosystem and
basically what happens is is from step
one to step two all we've done is we've
broken all of those bits of logic all of
those sections of the code that we're
running all in one big application we've
broken them out into their own smaller
services which is great but now we have
all this wiring in between so we've
introduced some complexity of the wiring
breaking a model with into into a
microservices now did we gain
performance reliability yeah if it's
done right absolutely but we've added
some type of complexity so when we're
moving from microservice infrastructure
or architecture into a full server love
stack we're introducing far more wiring
in between all the pieces so the
complexity is potentially much greater
for the overall application even if the
individual pieces of code that we as
engineers are managing are much much
simpler to maintain so the overall
application architecture we've got to be
aware of as we go and then all of this
of course is built on top of some type
of a platform that we're paying for or
we've spun up internally so Oh moving on
here here are some of the things that we
have to be aware of as the heading up
here says service is cheaper not
necessarily simpler anybody played with
us three much and had any issues with
eventual consistency
a couple hands awesome okay so if you're
not aware of what eventual consisted he
consistently and and I told miles I was
going to have to apologize to him I
don't know if he's in here all of my
examples are AWS I am intentionally
doing pretty generic examples because
these are things you can do on any
service provider I'm not doing a sales
pitch for AWS I just just what I know
the best but eventual consistency
basically means you can drop an object
into an s3 bucket for storage and it may
or may not be available for a read right
away because it has the replicated
across different data centers it's got
to replicate across regions and when
you're get requests or your pull request
goes back out if it hasn't replicated
all the way across you might hit a
bucket or region where it hasn't
propagated yet and so even though you
just wrote it you've got a success it
may not be available to read yet and so
we actually had a couple projects we're
like a server looks awesome we're gonna
do one lamb to here and it's going to
drop something into a three and then
it's gonna fire this thing off over here
and then the other lamp is gonna pick it
up and do more processing with it and it
wasn't there and the entire flow grinds
to a halt and we realized that oh we
need to call AWS guys so we can is on
the phone we're talking with them and
the question of course what did you read
the SLA no I didn't and s3 is eventual
consistency there is a window of time in
which they are still within their SLA
and as long as you can read it back out
within a certain length of time they're
okay and so these are things like the
fault tolerance a synchronicity is
you're doing multiple lambdas they're
stateless you've got things like this
that you have to start juggling where
you do it in an application level in a
monolith or even a microcircuit maintain
some type of state you now are
introducing logical chunks that are
stateless that have to be aware or be
able to retrieve or rebuild or saturate
or do something to be able to continue
processing and so things that before
were somewhat intuitive within the
application architecture are now
becoming things we have to manually
think through and deal with or at least
be aware of latency the only reason I
bring it up here
every new Network hop can introduce
latency so if you have something let's
say we've got three micro-services and
they're talking nicely together and
every new request hits all three of them
and it's a handoff you've got the
inbound request and then you've got at
least two hops so you've got three but
if we break that out and it turns into
six different lambdas or whatever you're
doubling the number of network
connections the network hops you're
having to make to process something so
you've got to be aware of the increased
latency potentially okay and again these
are all just be aware of them they're
not I'm not saying don't do it I'm just
saying be aware of what the potential
gotchas are let's see fault tolerance
what happens if an asynchronous lambda
spins up and fails and it can't process
and it's responding to something that it
pulled off of a queue have you thought
through what's your dead letter Q look
like are you going to actually do some
retry logic what is your fault tolerance
for it what's your retry all these
things we have to start thinking through
on a higher level or broader scale API
is messaging schemas how are you gonna
have all of the different pieces talk to
each other if they're on the same
process all of these different things
rolling up grades how do you manage your
actual upgrades of the individual
lambdas or whatever whatever piece
you're upgrading are you changing the
signature of the payload you're dropping
what what are all of the different
pieces like that ah let's see and
there's more so I've heard from a lot of
people that hey just do everything
serverless it's it's a solve all it'll
cure everything and it's really not if
you if you approach it as a cure-all if
you approach it as a silver bullet
that's gonna fix all of our problems I'm
afraid people are gonna be very
disappointed now again I say all of this
and I'm a very big proponent of using
serverless so don't get me wrong it is a
fantastic tool but as with any other
tool you've got to use the right tool
for the right job
and so every application if you're
considering server lists as a potential
architecture you need to evaluate your
actual system what it is you're trying
to build and what the benefits are what
is your ROI what's the cost going to be
how many requests are you gonna have
and we'll look at a couple examples here
in a minute where we can actually talk
through some of those concerns so let's
build a little bit this slide we're
going to talk through a couple of the
options in the AWS toolset that actually
we use regularly for service
applications so broader architectures
some of these are arguable they fall
into slightly different categories and
maybe somebody like well that's not pure
serverless that's the bass or something
yeah I get that but overall from a
service architecture standpoint here's a
few things to be aware of we use route
53 anytime we can to do dns resolution
because it ties so seamlessly into some
of the other pieces like the API gateway
if you have not looked into the API
management structures for several of the
different cloud providers API gateway is
great they're the the way you can define
and manage configuration for even
authentication and header parsing
different things like that
it's pretty pretty slick lambdas
themselves this is this is pretty
standard this is what every provider has
as their cloud functions you you provide
enough logic to run as a single logical
execution and you want to break it down
and make sure you don't throw too much
in there you're going to run within
restrictions in the different providers
such as within lambdas if you're running
more than I believe it's a five Meg
payload in a post request in or into the
context into the lambda is your your cap
it also has a time limit of a five
minute processing time so anything
beyond that and it will automatically
shut it down so there are things like
that you just have to be aware of which
will help you discern where in your
logic to slice up the pieces to make it
affordable and still be able to process
so lambdas um you see what's next s3
this is your object stores this is
basically I'm mmm AWS makes it very
distinct that it is not a static asset
store it is an object store you
basically could drop anything you want
in there this is the one that has given
us trouble with eventual consists
see you just have to be aware of that
and then we'll look at dynamodb this is
our new seek no sequel store highly
scalable incredibly fast connection
speeds read speeds write speeds and then
sqs the and the reason I threw these up
on here is because these are the ones
will actually talk through on a couple
of the architectural diagrams that we'll
look at in a moment so sqs is just what
it sounds like it's a queueing service
it's a hosted and managed queuing
service you set it up and you start
dropping items into it and then you can
reach out to it and check to see if
there's anything on the queue for you to
resolve and it supports both standard
queuing as well as 5o queuing so you can
you can do a lot of different things
with it
so one of the examples I'm going to talk
through is a problem space I ran into
where we had a couple api's internally
these were api's that had been spun up
and as we all know there's no such thing
as a proof-of-concept that stays a proof
of concept any time you show it to
somebody somebody starts using it and
now you have to support it and we had
several api's that had been built
internally for different teams and a
security audit came through and realized
that we had multiple api's that had
accessed the data that were not fronted
with any type of authentication now good
news is they were only on the internal
network however they still were not
fronted with authentication so we were
tasked with figuring out a way to try
and Front existing api's with basically
an OAuth style authentication of some
sort well we could give API keys out to
only those who need access to it and we
could do some type of token exchange to
grant access into those api's so if
you've ever done something like that
before where you've had an existing API
and you've had to try and put something
in front of it it can be extremely
challenging in this case we came up with
something that worked decently well see
if I can point over here essentially the
goal is we have an application layer
down here so this is something that was
already existing okay the applications
there the API is being hit but there's
no security layer in front of it and so
what we were able to do
is take a right here the API gateway and
set up a basically just an authorization
password exchange so you can take your
API key and your secret and you can hit
an endpoint here that will reach out
into the this is kind of where the
application layer I guess from the the
oauth thing that we created and there's
a lambda here that's your Authenticator
that really just checks your password if
you're in the the API keys that have
been granted it checks to make sure
you've got the appropriate role it
creates a new token it drops a token
into another DB table and another dynamo
table the reason we chose this
architecture is DynamoDB tables allow
you to specify a TTL on every item that
you drop into the table and at that TTL
it will auto expire that item and remove
it from your table so for this solution
it worked really well because if we had
you know let's say we had five minutes
oaken's and we only wanted them good for
a certain amount of time we could drop
them into our token table and they would
auto expire in that amount of time we
didn't have to do any manual cleanup
which was fantastic in this case once
that's done the Authenticator simply
returns with the token that they just
generated and the user or application
whatever it is it's hitting the end
point then can pick up that token pass
it off to the API that they were trying
to reach anyway and provide an
authorization header with a bearer token
on it that then fires off a secondary
lambda that all it knows how to do is
authorize the only thing this lambda
does is it takes the header and it looks
in here to see if it exists and if it
has the appropriate scopes for you to
execute what you're trying to execute an
api gateway right here actually has a
concept of authorizer and the authorizer
basically says you can check your token
you can build up an AWS what's the term
lost my lost my train of thought but you
basically build up your policy that's
what it is that grants our denies
as to what they're wanting and the API
gateway will receive that policy and
actually cache it at that layer so all
subsequent requests that that endpoint
will actually use the same policy that's
been cached so you can actually replay
tokens without having to overload the
number of executions of your lambdas
which ends up saving even more money so
I get a jump ahead I just got got the
signal here so application layer you end
up doing the handoff once everything has
been granted and you move forward this
one I think is a little more
approachable this is a full-on if we
wanted to do something like a mailing
list we could actually have the route 53
layer the DNS resolution had an API
gateway we can have the Gateway simply
drop payloads into like a registration
bucket so lambda can fire off mail great
yo you wanted to register we're gonna
drop drop your email address into a
dynamo DB table and then you might have
an administrator come in later and want
to actually send an email and they can
hit a different endpoint on the API
gateway and it'll kick you over and
build up a queue of all the emails that
need to be sent and then you can process
them however you like I want to jump
real quick and see if I can do a quick
demo or not so give me one moment I've
got just a couple minutes here and
alright so this is a whirlwind I will
tell you now I'm going to probably have
to cut this very short so if you have
questions or you want to walk through
this with me later please find me I'm
happy to talk through as much of this as
I can
API gateway essentially allows you to
just specify all of your endpoints like
you would it's almost if you've used
swagger or anything like that or or you
use happy Jas or anything that where you
can do a declarative style ap is or
routes that's basically what we can do
here and then you wire it up directly to
a lambda so you've got up here you see
the type as a lambda proxy on the
integration request basically what that
tells the api gateway to do is to do a
little bit of pre-processing and
create a context that's going to hand
off to your lambda function and so then
you write a little bit of node in your
lambdas over here slow there we go if
that loads that's great but there's some
node it's just a function that accepts a
context and some additional parameters
depending on the type of lambda you want
there's a lot more complexity I'm
smoothing a little bit of it over but it
gets handed of context from that context
you can basically look at the payload
that was parsed out you can look at the
headers you can make all kinds of
different decisions within your lambda
of what to do further and so in this
case I'm trying to load the email
sending one in this case we would
actually grab from dynamodb our entire
list of emails that have been registered
we would then take the body that was
sent to us and we just kind of line them
up together and send off an email to
each one of the users so it's a really
really rudimentary email management or
marketing type thing but that's that's
essentially all that there is in it is
the ability to wire up your API directly
into a lambda that knows how to process
glean the data that's been dropped in
from somewhere else so that never did
load did it nope all right well come to
be later well we'll run through it so
again that's all this this diagram is
showing in this case what I was doing is
dropping it into a queue and SQS and
then we'd be able to pull that queue and
pull off the generated emails to send
off you could have an iron port or
something like that to actually process
major email loads so besides that a
little bit of homework there are
multiple multiple multiple things to
consider we have not talked about this
is a very high level we have things like
I am roles you've got security models
you've got VPC for your private cloud
you have Direct Connect which I did
mention which lets you run things on
your internal or business network so
that you can actually control your
security a little bit better or have
security shared between internal and
cloud applications if you're using my
sequel Postgres something like that
there are
Frings to let you do that with your
database and let them scale it or host
it for you and again by them pretty much
all the providers have this type of
thing you've got caching layers you've
got all kinds of different things you
can use to to accent or complement the
serverless offerings we've looked at to
build out a much broader and more secure
application so I just did the demo and
so that's it thank you very much
[Applause]